let me set this up she goes jenna when
you're ready i need you to come to my
trailer i have the best tick tock
planned for us it's like hysterical i
like his prep since last night all you
need to do is sit there and stare at me
while i just like throw a tantrum and
kick things i'm like okay so i come on
over i'm like sitting i'm watching her
go
falls
up like three steps off flat on her back
wait for it
they say i'm bad they say i'm evil
jojo siwa is getting candid about her
tick tock fail with her dancing with the
star's pro partner jenna johnson
straight on her back
rolled ankle on my knee on my back my
hand is messed up
that wasn't planned but being the good
sport she is the pop star laughed it off
wait for it
they say i'm bad they say i'm evil
i was like is this happening right now
what's going on i will tell you
if i break my arm oh my gosh
nobody here will know i will get through
our dance because if some medic says
that i can't dance i will get through it
i'm gonna show up to do the descendants
i will be there with burning bloody
scars on me and i will be in my costume
i will get that wig on you might have to
dress up without me but i will be there
thankfully jojo made it to the dancing
with the stars disney villains night
injury-free
[Music]
the pair embraced their wicked sides
while performing a passa doble to
fittingly ways to be wicked from
descendants 2. and the performance was a
hit with the judges they earned a score
of 35 out of 40.
[Music]
following the show jenna and jojo spoke
with e.t and they opened up about what
it was like tapping into their darker
sides it was fun it
it was definitely a contrast yesterday
we had to be in love with each other and
today
we had to want to murder each other
um
remind me i have a good tick tock for
you
um you're gonna love it um
it it was it was definitely hard i mean
jenna's literally my best friend my
favorite human in the world and i
don't ever want to kill her and don't
ever want to murder her so just play
like i want you for a minute and a half
was genuinely a struggle the triple
threat also shared how she handles
criticism and always strives to lead by
example i think that i know i'm not the
first person who's been hated on and i'm
definitely not the last person who's
been hated on i am somebody who wants to
inspire other people and i think that
i'm lucky enough
and blessed enough to have a platform
and to have a voice i think obviously
i'm 18. i don't know everything about
everything but
i do know right from wrong and i do know
when i'm faced with the situation what's
right and what's wrong
and i will
always do everything in my power to make
sure that i choose what's right and what
will make other people happy and that's
something that we talked about actually
this week that i struggle with is
sometimes i don't make myself happy
but it doesn't matter in my head because
i'm making other people happy and i just
want to do what other people like and
something that jenna told me this week
she said
you have to be selfish for once right
now you have to take a second think
about you and you have to do what you
have to do right now and i was like
that's
true and i've never thought that before
and so i'm learning as i go but
i'm finding a balance of how to make
sure everybody rounds me happy i'm happy
the world is happy
so it's a battle that's really hard to
win but my goal is to win it